Marvel Studios may have been giddy beyond
compare about re-releasing Avengers: Endgame,
but some Marvel fans feel differently.
The house of heroes launched a special version
of Avengers: Endgame in theaters on June 28th,
offering viewers a chance to see this year's
biggest superhero movie with a few extra features
tacked on to either end of its three-hour
runtime.
Not an extended or alternate cut of the film,
the Endgame re-release included an introduction
from co-director Anthony Russo, a tribute
to the late Stan Lee, an unfinished deleted
scene focused on Mark Ruffalo's Professor
Hulk, and footage from Spider-Man: Far From
Home, the final film in Phase 3 of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe.
Many Marvelites headed out to theaters over
the weekend to feast their eyes on the Avengers:
Endgame re-release and were solely disappointed
by what they saw.
From misunderstanding what kind of footage
the re-release would feature to being underwhelmed
by the post-credits extras to even finding
the bonus content cheap-looking, fans are
upset by the Endgame re-release.
And they are tweeting that rage.
@nctaliaromanova kicked things off, saying,
"Save your money for black widow (2020) instead
of the endgame re-release because i've never
been so disappointed in my life."
Twitter user @natasharogers_ wrote
"I am so disappointed and strongly recommend
you not watching it, it is a waste of money."
Meanwhile, @bizgamer9 said he liked it fine,
but that's because he just wanted to see the
movie
again.
"If that hadn't been the case I would be more
disappointed with what they added.
Seriously, if you're going in wanting new
stuff then don't go at all and wait for the
Blu-ray."
Countless others were upset with themselves
for not doing enough fact-finding about the
Endgame re-release beforehand.
One fan said they were, quote, "literally
a fool" for thinking that they would get to
see the deleted scene featuring Katherine
Langford as an older Morgan Stark, the daughter
of Robert Downey Jr.'s Tony Stark.
“Hahaha!
You fool!
You fell victim to one of the classic blunders!”
@daniel6711_ summed things up, writing,
"The deleted scenes they added at the end
of the movie were the most pointless scenes.
It was a hulk deleted scene and a far from
home sneak peek.
The only thing nice about it was the Stan
Lee tribute and the free poster."
Many Marvel fans are particularly angry about
the poor quality of the never-before-seen
Hulk scene.
@FilmCriticKurt tweeted,
"I'm so disappointed and furious with the
re-release of Avengers: Endgame.
The new footage was terrible.
PS2 level CGI with no impact on story and
some fluff content.
Do not spend money on this!"
Added user @ZachCR_,
"Tbh the re-release bonus content for Avengers
EndGame was really poor quality, and almost
looked Fan-Made...
Seems like kind of a cash grab.
Very disappointed."
The idea that the re-release was spurred by
a desire to make more money is, of course,
obviously true.
Marvel was specifically hoping that revenue
from the re-release would allow the film to
pass James Cameron's Avatar as the highest
grossing film in box office history, as Endgame
entered the weekend trailing by just $37 million.
It seems that some fans were outraged by the
lengths Marvel and parent company Disney went
to squeeze more juice out of Endgame, with
@SherrieGies slamming the re-release as a
"[...] blatant cash grab by disney bc they
know they'll make millions off of ppl who
live and breathe for marvel movies [...]"
To make matters worse, Avengers: Endgame didn't
even end up beating Avatar with its re-release
over the weekend, taking in just $5.5 million
domestically.
It looks like it may never surpass the Cameron-directed
film, with The Hollywood Reporter writing
that media analysts believe that, quote, "it
would be impossible" for Avengers: Endgame
to top Avatar unless Marvel re-released the
film again at some point in the future.
Everything considered, it seems like the bonus
content included in the Avengers: Endgame
re-release wasn't worth the cost of entry
for many Marvel fans.
It's unlikely that this backlash will tarnish
the studio's reputation, given just how beloved
the MCU is, but it will probably make Marvel
and Disney think twice about how they approach
re-releasing movies down the line… if they
ever do.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Marvel heroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.